[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cécile mans comptant examineront oui
parce qu'allah je suis pas venu les
mains vides de la politique j'ai du
sport de la télé j'ai même du bipôle
avec un petit indice de type fruitiers
et moi tu nous avons qui sauf que
téléspectateurs plutôt énormément et mes
amis merci mairie les drogues cocaïne
[Applaudissements]
avec l'entrée
oui en fait j'ai presque envie que tu
restes à la table ce soir à brest un peu
après mais je suis pas prêt il ya plus
de place
brancher un appareil à raclette
politiquement c'est de la politique est
vivement
vous le savez l'important en politique
c'est de savoir écouter tous ses
concitoyens
le great old republic que emmanuel ma
clown c'est président directeur mois
mais il a été relégué les news on parle
un petit peu plus effectivement en tout
cas ils possèdent nuit il cette qualité
d'écouté et c'est tant mieux on le
regarde sept points de suture n'a voulu
aller sécuriser le pas de vivre l'amour
ce soir on va se retrouver piégé le
courant d'eau se déporter sur le plus
c'est que ça tombe bien
en faire une marche à 5h l'écoutent
alors je politique toujours mythique
encore encore
on adore vous le savez l'importance
politique c'est de savoir de quête de
quoi de quoi ton cause surtout de couacs
en cause dans un micro nicolas bay ne
connaît que je suis de là bas je me suis
dit je tiens je me lance et le
rassemblement national du rassemblement
on se lance une balle qui l'a fait
nicolas bay du rationnement nationale
effectivement on a fait les frais comme
vous le savez nicolas bay ne craint
personne
regardez c'est une équipe qui sera six
pays pour moi hier de demandeurs d'asile
l'albanie haïti qu'ils ne sont pas des
pays en guerre lorsque karine juste de
vous reprendre les principaux demandeurs
d'asile en europe sont viennent de syrie
d'afghanistan et du venezuela et donc
pas d'haïti ou d'alain savait pas quelle
année vous prenez en 2010 mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que la france est un des
pays qui a eu finalement le plus grand
nombre de morts par habitant non c'est
parmi les plus agiles en ondes
il ya la belgique est juste devant nous
mais on n'est pas de ceux qui s'en
sortent le mieux la belgique est très
loin de leur nez enfin je parle dans
mort par habitant et italie aussi
l'espagne également cesser le royaume
uni aussi voir son débit qui sont pires
que nous c'est ce que je dis sur 27 pays
en attendant on est dans le peloton des
quatre ou cinq où il ya le plus de morts
par habitant comment sinon
la révision
ultime arrêt et un exploit et score
alors c'est pas par là bas surtout de la
cuisse de jupiter de la cuisine porter
mois passent
après avoir remporté le contrat de
diffusion des matchs de foot de ligue 1
mediapro est en cessation de paiement
est vendeur et se retrouve maintenant au
bord du gouffre en exclusivité voici les
réactions de tous les protagonistes de
ce marché ô combien juteux
[Rires]
vous verrez
c'est ce qu'on appelle un poil à gratter
sur wii d'ailleurs ce n'est pas vraiment
une photo de moi ça je vous ai envoyés
pour les petites filles de l'année randy
pas trop d'agriculteurs de la mayenne a
fait une découverte bien ni d'attendus
dans son champ de maïs l'agriculteur
soupçonne les équipes de l'émission
l'amour est dans le pré d'être passé par
là visiblement l'amour se fait aussi
dans le prêt à regarder et c'est une
bonne chose
c'est complètement découvert plus le
sex-toy dans son show maïs exactement
c'est hinault et si vous vous
dernièrement 7e apparemment elle a perdu
sa zigounette baby est la même couleur
que lui battre a dit paul pour finir
paul bybowl souvenez-vous en 2003 le
chanteur michel et michalak niko ça je
sais même pas qui gémit jennifer 12
michel en tout cas de la star ac nous
avaient sous les nous avait enchantés
s'adorent joliment avec son énorme tube
qui a volé le range mais il revient
sept ans effectivement on s'en rappelle
il revient de 17 ans après avec la même
chanson on écoute je n'oublie pas ce
qu'on s'enlève qui avait volé cet orange
défini effectivement une enquête est en
cours je ne peux faire aucune
déclaration
simplement que j'ai une petite idée
cyril de la chanson que michal va sortir
en 2045
et effectivement au bout d'un moment
faudra bien qu'il la retrouve cette
orange parce qu'il commence à nous
gonfler regarder suivez dessus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]